so good to see you sydney and jordan i
just watched a film last night i have to
know were you guys fascinated with the
royals before making this film
um i would say i had a healthy interest
in them
i watched the wedding you know i watched
cherry megan's wedding and um
i definitely watched the oprah interview
so but that i i didn't dive deep until
until doing this movie yeah you kind of
can't escape them you know yeah the
movie then you kind of go deeper into
the details
yeah and talking about the oprah
interview what were your thoughts when
you watched it because i mean you were
probably absorbed into this world
already by harry meghan
what did you feel like when you watched
that interview
um i felt like it was
history
in the making for sure i mean it was
very vulnerable um and surprising and
kind of reminded me of you know of
diana's interviews and um so i knew
people would be talking about it but i
was really impressed with how they they
both
handled like very sensitive material
and yourself jordan
yeah i would just say their candor you
know their poise and their in their
candor was um
pretty remarkable um and their openness
about the subjects that they were
talking about
um
they're pretty revealing or at least
revealing to a point
but in in that sense very revealing
because you know they're they're very
um closed off historically so their
their honesty
was refreshing but also really revealing
sydney the fact that you said the
historical moment you think about megan
being a woman of color yourself a woman
of color and being in this industry and
her speaking her truth how did that feel
for yourself
uh i was really
moved um and i feel like it
and i'm sure it did this for a lot of
women
of color that it brought up a lot of
my own experience um
and you know obviously not on a global
scale
and not under such scrutiny but i think
a lot of the
feelings of isolation and otherness and
um that feeling of
you know
not being
taught the language but being expected
to be very good at it right away you
know the expectations versus the
preparation and all of that like that
really resonated with me and um
yeah i i felt like you know i wanted to
i wanted to be her friend in that moment
because i all of us right yes yeah it
was a powerful moment and for you two to
see yourself transform into harry and
meghan to see yourself in the mirror and
say
you look like them i mean what was that
like for you
fun
to be able to play someone that's alive
today and there's there's challenges
with that there's pressure to that
um as an actor that's sort of what you
sort of dream of and to get a chance to
do that alongside sydney and the rest of
the cast was a blast yeah yeah we got to
paint on every individual freckle you
know i mean i think it's very detailed
and by the end of you know the two and a
half hours of doing that you're you
you're ready to play that person you
feel transformed mm-hmm
and you know you have to stay neutral as
actors as you mentioned like the fact
you're taking on these characters who
are alive but
do you have an opinion now on megan and
harry do you believe everything they
said do you believe the firm do you
believe what was going on like there's
so many questions out there but what are
your thoughts now being so absorbed in
the storyline
i need to know
um i think you know
it's
again we have to stay neutral while
we're playing these roles but
i try to make it
my mo to not judge what other people do
and feel they need to do for their
families for their relationships
um and
this was a family decision this was
something that they
you wouldn't make a decision like this
um with any kind of cavalier attitude
you wouldn't do it just to get a
reaction like not because you know how
strong the reaction's gonna be so they
obviously felt very strongly and um are
doing it for their family so i i respect
that
you're saying quiet jordan what did you
think
no i think it's it's their their truth
you know i
i i honestly i think and as an actor you
sort of keep all that
outside it and you sort of just yeah
always on the text and obviously in the
text you're trying to find the truth and
an emotional truth and and uh that's
sort of what i'm
not leave me for the whole
did you learn anything yeah did you
learn anything about harry that you were
surprised by
yeah well i mean he was speaking openly
while we were
while we were filming so um we were
getting new information
in sort of
real time as we were as we were filming
some some of these scenes
he was speaking openly about his mental
health and the toll
um you know his mother's passing has has
taken on him and the press and the
pressure of that life
uh and the fear that you know history
would or could repeat itself
with megan and that's you know stakes
are enormous
that's life and death to him and so i
think
hearing him speak openly about these
things that
um for someone who's in the royal family
to speak openly about and honestly about
and really show a vulnerability
um was not only like impressive but also
um
showed another side of him that i also
wanted to show
in the film as well
yeah you did a brilliant job you did
such a good job so absorbed into here
and like he's such a nice guy he's doing
it family it's so nicely done what does
it feel like the idea they may watch
this film they may watch themselves you
guys acting like them what
have you thought about that
oh yeah
i think the second you get cast in
something like this you're like oh wow
these are real people who are still
alive and you know
obviously not living under a rock so
they probably will catch wind of this
um
yeah i mean knowing that they could
watch it i i think definitely affected
how we approached the movie you were
like let's handle this with care with
respect
this is you know their life their
traumas their family that we're talking
about so
you know you don't want to again you
don't want to treat it like it's just a
headline some tabloid story
you